mesdames mesdemoiselles bonjour
aujourd'hui on est où on est à Prague et
à Prague qu'est-ce qui se passe et bien
après qu'on fait du hockey sur glace bon
c'est pas le sujet même si j'ai ramené
un petit palais de hockey sur glace
c'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui non
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe c'est qu'on
va se parler d'un smartphone j'en ai
profité pour venir ici prendre un peu de
temps et vous parler d'un smartphone que
j'aime bien et donc je vous ai déjà
ce smartphone vous le connaissez c'est
le Honor Magic 5 Pro j'ai déjà fait des
trucs avec je voulais déjà montré et
donc on va se regarder aujourd'hui le
Honor Magic 5 Pro du côté de la photo du
côté de la vidéo mais je pouvais pas
aller à Prague sans vous faire faire
déjà le fameux tour de ma pioles ça
j'aime bien regarder on est après là où
je suis dans l'hôtel c'est pas très
évident il y a la salle de sport en face
c'est pas la meilleure vue qu'on puisse
avoir sur Prague mais bon on est quand
même sur Prague et puis surtout j'aime
bien vous faire visiter les petites
chambres d'hôtel avec regardez coucou je
suis en face de l'autre côté avec une
toute petite salle de bain c'est un
petit hôtel qui s'appelle l'hôtel Joseph
à Prague donc ça hop c'est moi je suis
là petite salle de bain c'est beau c'est
mignon mais c'est pas le sujet le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est quoi
au nord ça nous prend du côté
de ça on va le faire bien évidemment
dans les rues de Prague allez on y va
on commence par faire un petit tour du
côté matériel vous avez un triptyque ici
c'est trois capteurs 50 mégapixels grand
angle ultra grand-angle tel objectif sur
sachant que votre ultra grand-angle va
également faire Macron et vous avez un
zoom optique X3 et demi qui est
stabilisé qu'on va retrouver ici et une
caméra de selfie de 12 mégapixels
en fait il y a trois trucs qui sont
super importants ici sur ce smartphone
trois éléments technologiques qui sont
vraiment différents et super
différenciant et très très important le
premier c'est le Falcon engine c'est la
nouvelle techno que nous propose au nord
cette année c'est à dire que votre
smartphone il va venir shooter
extrêmement rapidement par exemple je
prends mon smartphone voyez je me mets
un endroit j'appuie directement ça shoot
ça shoot ça shoute ça chute ça choute
chouchoute la caméra je choque tout donc
ça saute très très rapidement donc ça
c'est vraiment un point qui est
important c'est à dire qu'il y a un
nouvel algorithme qui a mis ici au nord
à l'intérieur ton smartphone c'est le
capture Falcon milliskon qui va venir
shooter vraiment extrêmement rapidement
donc ça voyez vous venez shooter vous
appuyez ça shoot ça shoot ça shoot ça
shoot ça shoot ça shoot quel que soit
l'endroit où vous allez être et quel que
soit les conditions de luminosité ici il
fait beau il fait quasiment chaud mais
si vous êtes dans des conditions de nuit
tiables luminosité ça va aussi améliorer
significativement ajouter beaucoup plus
rapidement et puis surtout ça va
améliorer significativement envoyé par
exemple je vais lancer mon application
je veux changer de mode quel que soit
les choses que je vais faire ça va vite
je prends une photo sympa et ça vient la
processer directement très rapidement
donc ça c'est vachement bien l'autre
point qui est aussi important c'est la
détection de mouvement paria je vous
explique par exemple je prends mon
smartphone vient le lancer et là je vais
venir shooter vous voyez par exemple
cette petite icône là en bas à gauche je
viens appuyer dessus ça m'active la
détection de mouvement donc ça c'est
cool et après je peux cliquer juste en
haut à gauche pour la mettre automatique
alors je vous explique c'est à dire que
si je mets pas l'automatique et que je
vois par exemple un skateur un mouvement
quoi qu'il se passe et bien je déclenche
sur un mouvement ça va venir enregistrer
une seconde avant que j'appuie et
ensuite 0,5 secondes après et ensuite il
y a va faire le boulot automatiquement
et reconnaître la meilleure scène donc
ça c'est cool mais si par exemple je
vais le faire attention complètement
automatique et bien gardé j'en puis en
haut à gauche je viens poser mon
smartphone par là je vérifie que la
scène soit bien faite je viens de poser
ça va reconnaître un mouvement et par
exemple si je saute là vous voyez ça va
reconnaître le mouvement ça va venir
shooter la scène où je saute le plus
haut voyez celle-là et ça c'est
vachement bluffant parce que vous voyez
j'ai ces deux scènes là où je venus
sauter et c'est là où je suis le plus
haut c'est très net il y a pas de flou
de bouger je trouve ça juste extrêmement
bluffant donc là dessus je reconnais que
la techno elle est dingue regardez la
photo elle est juste quasiment parfaite
je saute ça bouge pas c'est net il y a
personne qui est venu appuyer vous
l'avez vu il a fait de façon
complètement automatique non mais
regardez-moi ce truc c'est juste
hallucinant je suis en plein mouvement
on a l'impression que je suis à la cool
peinard comme ça je prends la pause et
celle que vous avez là c'est pareil
alors bon je fais pas une tête très
expressive mais pour autant ça bouge pas
et ça y est je peux même faire ça et
j'ai l'impression que je suis en train
de bouger en l'air un peu comme dans
Matrix Bullet Time alors on va quand
même bien un peu le nuage on va bien un
petit peu que ça bouge en bas mais sinon
c'est juste extrêmement bluffant et si
je viens zoomer une fois de plus je
regarde c'est net mais là c'est on voit
qu'ils sont mouvement mais il y a pas de
flou de bouger nulle part au niveau des
doigts pareil c'est net les cheveux ça
bouge pas c'est net et si vous regardez
pareil la deuxième photo c'est
exactement la même chose je dois
reconnaître que je fais extrêmement
bluffé et ça ça montre quoi ça montre
que ça joue tellement rapidement que on
n'a pas le temps d'avoir ce flou de
bouger ça prend ça des textes ça fait
son petit calcul d'un point de vue il y
a algorithmique et c'est fou et le rendu
est juste mais juste complètement dingue
et la troisième techno principale qu'on
vient retrouver ici sur ce Honor Magic 5
Pro bon la connaissait déjà l'année
dernière c'est l'ultra fusion en fait
qu'est-ce qui se passe et bien lorsque
vous allez venir shooter une photo votre
smartphone va venir utiliser les
différents capteurs pour vous faire une
seule et même photo que ce soit sur le
grand angle ultra grand-angle une telle
objectif pour vous apporter la meilleure
netteté le plus de détails la meilleure
gestion de la lumière bref une
optimisation totalement transparente
pour vous mais derrière vous avez cet
algo qui vient pédaler et qui va vous
donner vraiment des photos d'une extrême
qualité bon allez je vous ramène dans
les rues de Prague
[Musique]
première chose qu'on va venir regarder
c'est les photos un peu de base avec
l'objectif grand-angle je vous l'avais
dit dans ma précédente vidéo mais je
vous le redis une fois de plus ici vous
allez voir les photos sont vraiment très
très belles ça c'est une photo qui est
prise à Prague on a vraiment beaucoup de
piquets c'est très beau un ciel très
préservé le soleil en contre-jour qui ne
pose aucun problème des détails sur le
côté une colorimétrie qui est belle qui
est juste personnellement c'est une très
jolie photo ici je vous emmène alors sur
un ciel un peu plus grisé au bord de
l'océan ça marche c'est joli sur le
contre-jour une fois de plus ça
fonctionne vraiment très très bien des
couleurs qui sont très juste pas trop
saturés ça c'est vraiment bien alors bon
je vous montre quelques huîtres je sais
pas si vous aimez les huîtres moi j'aime
bien regardez c'est vraiment beau il y a
un côté assez neutre au niveau de ses
photos certaines marques ont tendance un
petit peu trop sursaturer les photos ici
c'est pas le cas ça raconte une belle
histoire et je trouve que c'est vraiment
un point fort qu'on a sur ce smartphone
c'est voyez là j'ai ça en premier plan
le flou est très joli très très doux ça
marche très très bien et je dois
reconnaître que vraiment ici au nord à
super bien bossé sur le capteur grand
angle de son Honor m'a dit que 5 Pro
sans aucun problème quand vous avez plus
de soleil forcément ça va sublimer
davantage et là sur des paysages marins
je trouve ça juste magnifique regardez
vous avez pas mal de soleil ça pète ça
peut être mais c'est beau et c'est pas
trop ici c'est pareil très belle couleur
j'aime beaucoup une fois de plus les
ambiances c'est ce qui vient se dégager
de ces photos prises avec sonore magique
c'est le pro bon maintenant salut ultra
grand-angle ultra grand-angle aussi est
bien alors vous allez voir ça donne
forcément un peu plus d'espace c'est
l'ultra grand-angle c'est pas déformant
on a un peu moins de piqué fatalement
que sur le grand angle pour autant le
résultat est quand même très jolie
écoute un peu plus violine en gros si
vous voyez au niveau du ciel mais une
fois de plus je trouve qu'il y a un truc
qui est bien c'est qu'il y a une
ambiance particulière qui est restituée
et que je trouve vraiment très juste et
très jolie donc ça c'est un truc que
j'aime bien une fois de plus et que ce
smartphone n'arrive vraiment bien à à
ramener vous voyez sur des grands
paysages de plage comme ça c'est
magnifique là j'adore cette photo vous
pouvez tout le détail qu'on a dans le
ciel ici typiquement ça marche vraiment
bien là toutes les ambiances aussi une
fois de plus balade dans les forêts de
pain j'adore cette photo je la trouve
très très belle vous voyez ça c'est
magnifique donc c'est ultra grand-angle
il vous permet de capter davantage
d'immensité on va perdre fatalement on
le voit là tout autour ici là on perd
vraiment en détail mais pour autant tout
ce qui est central ça marche bien et
c'est très très joli donc moi
personnellement c'est un grand oui je
suis convaincu même avec le soleil ici à
contre-jour ça marche bien en ville
aussi ça marche bien et une fois de plus
j'aime beaucoup le résultat ici
maintenant on va regarder le
téléobjectif voir jusqu'où on peut aller
alors téléobjectif vous allez voir il y
a des
trucs bien fois trois et demi optique il
est très très bien jusqu'au x c'est bien
et dès qu'on se rapproche trop tout de
suite voyez c'est pas terrible mais ça
devient relativement non exploitable
tout ce qu'on a à faire jusqu'au x 10 ça
va x 3 et demi c'est vraiment impeccable
x 10 voilà mais au-delà de ça on va
venir éviter c'est pas le gros point
fort ici qu'on va voir sur le
téléobjectif mais je vous le dis une
fois de plus si on vient zoomer dans de
la demi-mesure et qu'on fait attention
et qu'on va pas trop loin et qu'on va
pas pousser le smartphone jusqu'à zoom
numérique fois 100 et bien on sort quand
même des résultats qui sont très jolis
là vous voyez sur un fauteuil me
regardez c'est quand même très très
sympa comme ça donc dans l'ensemble ça
marche quand même vachement bien mais on
va pas trop trop loin voyez on peut
venir ajouter des choses comme ça que
j'aime beaucoup là je devais être en
faux 10 à mon avis je viens zoomer dans
le numérique un petit peu mais j'arrive
quand même à sortir des choses qui sont
pas mal alors là on voit qu'il y a à
côté un petit peu numérique là qu'on
vient retrouver ici au niveau des vagues
là mais pour autant il y a de la matière
et c'est joli regardez là c'est quand
même classe et maintenant on va se
regarder la macro parce qu'on utilise
l'ultra grand-angle pour faire la macro
on a un capteur 50 mégapixels donc on va
regarder si le rendu intéressant à
maquereau pas du tout je dois
reconnaître que c'est plutôt rare que
j'aime les les macros au niveau des
smartphones mais là c'est bien maîtrisé
comme on est sur ce capteur ultra
grand-angle de 50 mégapixels on peut
venir vraiment se rapprocher et ça nous
emmène de la matière ça nous domaine du
détail regardez alors je sais pas si
vous aimez pas les huîtres et si ça vous
dégoûte je suis sincèrement désolé mais
regardez tout ce qu'on arrive à trouver
en terme de lumière en termes de détails
partout sur la photo sont pour autant
que il y a un côté un peu avec un espèce
de bruit numérique qui sait pas le cas
donc c'est vraiment bien il y a un côté
un peu lisser là mais sur la matière
naturelle donc c'est pas artificiel et
ça marche bien je vous emmène sur du
coquillage là aussi ça marche très très
bien des mois le détail sur le
coquillage on récupère vraiment quelque
chose qui est jolie alors là j'ai essayé
de shooter quelques petites bulles à
l'océan c'est pareil on voit bien
regarder si vous regardez là vous venez
zoom un petit peu là les petits grains
de sable qu'on voit à travers la bulle
je trouve ça très jolie vous voyez là
les petites bulles d'écume en fait et
maintenant on se regarde la caméra de
selfie ce que j'aime bien sur cette
caméra de selfie c'est que on n'est pas
sur des pots très lissés on vient
souvent retrouver ça chez certains
constructeurs chinois et si c'est pas le
cas on garde vraiment tous les traits du
visage alors fatalement on va être moins
bon la définition va être moins jolie
que ce qu'on a sur le capteur arrière
mais je trouve que dans l'ensemble le
boulot est quand même vraiment bien fait
que vous soyez à contre-jour pas
contre-jour et du détail de tous les
côtés c'est bien maîtrisé la
colorimétrie est juste pour ramener du
souvenir c'est bien alors c'est pas
aussi bien
vous êtes du mode portrait mais par
contre si je veux mon vrai mode portrait
là j'ai un vrai fou derrière plan qui
marche bien c'est cool et ça c'est je
pense aussi du grâce à la caméra 3D que
vous avez devant parce que je vous ai
déjà expliqué quand je vous ai présenté
ce smartphone vous avez effectivement
deux modules photos à l'avant on va voir
une première caméra qui va être là et
bien c'est la caméra de selfie le
deuxième c'est un module de
reconnaissance en trois dimensions qui
vous permet de déverrouiller votre
smartphone grâce à votre visage comme
vous le feriez sur une autre marque de
smartphone qui vous le fait directement
avec la reconnaissance en 3D pour venir
mapper en 3D et également venir le
piloter avec des gestes ça je voulais
montrer dans l'autre vidéo je vous
invite à venir acheter un coup d’œil
donc vous voyez cette fonctionnalité
elle est cool et ça vous permet d'avoir
ce mode portrait directement avec votre
caméra de selfie et d'ailleurs puisqu'on
parle du mode portrait on va regarder
toutes les photos prises avec le mode
portrait le mode portrait est aussi joli
et je veux dire joli tout le temps je
vais arrêter de dire jolie mais c'est
vrai que j'aime beaucoup une fois de
plus ce mode portrait si vous venez
regarder un peu le détail et qu'on a
notamment ici au niveau des cheveux
voyez le contour est bien fait c'est
bien maîtrisé il y a pas un bout de
cheveux qui va venir se mélanger avec le
ciel là c'est pareil au niveau des
épaules c'est maîtrisé donc il y a une
vraie maîtrise logiciel ici alors là au
niveau des doigts je vous ai mis
histoire de venir regarder voyez tout le
contour qui est fait là il est bien
est-ce que là il a eu un peu de mal ou
pas peut-être très légèrement là mais
globalement c'est vraiment pas grand
chose et faites voir sur celui-là voyez
peut-être on pourrait venir j'ai un bout
de doigt qui était bouffé là mais c'est
vraiment pas grand chose une fois de
plus pour moi ici au nord a vraiment
bien également bossé sa copie au niveau
du mode portrait qu'on vient retrouver
faites voir sur les lunettes là alors il
m'a peut-être bouffé un tout petit bout
ici quoi que même pas voyez un petit
bout au niveau de la lunette il a eu un
petit peu de mal mais sinon là si on
vient regarder là vous voyez dans là ça
va peut-être légèrement là mais ça vient
se manger donc ça va je trouve ça bien
et même là sur le mode portrait en
caméra de selfie et bien le job est bien
fait aussi alors un peu moins bien fait
au niveau du détour c'est venu à peu me
faire une tête un peu ronde mais
globalement c'est quand même bien fait
alors un peu moins bien je vais mettre
un petit bémol regardez là on le voit
notamment ici par rapport à ce que j'ai
sur la caméra arrière mais sur la caméra
avant on peut faire du mode portrait si
on souhaite également alors là je vous
ai montré tout ce qui était photo sur ce
smartphone mais il y a plein de vidéos
et c'est justement un truc qui vachement
attention il y a plein de vidéos je sais
pas si ça se dit il y a plein de vidéos
bref il y a moins de vidéos qui est
complet regardez donc sur mon mode vidéo
je vais avoir un mode un petit peu
normal alors je vous montre rapidement
les paramètres pour vous voyez un petit
peu on peut filmer en 4K en 16:9 on peut
filmer en 4K 21/9 personnellement la 16
9 c'est ce qui me va bien ici vous
choisissez le nombre d'images par
seconde 30 images par seconde ça me va
60 vous allez rajouter des images on
vous pourrez faire du ralenti pourquoi
pas et surtout le truc qui est cool
c'est qu'il y a un mode film après mais
je vous montrerai c'est plus un mode
plus professionnel alors le mode un peu
classique là vous allez être comme ça on
peut avoir l'ultra grand-angle également
il est stabilisé sous très grand angle
c'est quand même pas mal c'est toi avec
moi vous voyez qu'il y a toujours un peu
la tremblotte ça sort un truc qui est
pas dégueu après on passe directement en
X 4 tout en sachant qu'ici c'est un zoom
optique x 3 et demi donc là on est déjà
en numérique et après le X 10 on en
parle pas on peut venir zoomer si on
veut mais pas plus que ça donc bon voilà
un petit peu déjà ce qu'on peut venir
faire de façon un peu classique mais ce
qui va nous intéresser surtout nous
c'est le mode Film le mode film il est
cool pourquoi et ben parce qu'en fait
vous avez différentes options qui sont
très très cool alors hop là je déplace
le petit bazar là c'est à dire que vous
avez un mode lutte le mode lutte en fait
ça donne une colorimétrie donc ça c'est
la colorimétrie classique on va passer
en éclat de soleil voyez on a du choix
focus bravo on va voir l'éblouissante
est très éblouissant comme ça coco en
pure on va avoir nostalgie on va voir le
lugubre ça te va bien ça le légume et
après vous voyez vous avez des petites
démonstrations aussi sont assez cool et
qui vous montre ce qu'on peut venir en
faire ça c'est bien parce que on peut se
projeter un peu dans ce qu'on peut venir
créer directement avec ces modes là vous
voyez que le soleil ça vous donne un
truc un petit peu automnale voilà tout
ça c'est marrant donc voilà donc ça
c'est délai c'est une colorimétrie qui
vient se mettre directement sur votre
smartphone après vous avez le mode blog
et le mode log moi c'est plus qui va
m'intéresser c'est à dire que je vais
filmer dans un mode qui est totalement
plate totalement plate c'est à dire
qu'il y a pas de colorimétrie je viens
de choper tous les spectre de couleur et
d'image et ça permettra vraiment de
venir retravailler après en
post-production si je veux l'utiliser
comme l'outil professionnel donc c'est
vraiment un outil qui va être assez
passe partout vous voyez là je suis en
train de filmer comme ça alors on va
essayer de filmer un peu différentes
choses et je vous ferai une petite
colorimétrie dessus après pour vous
montrer donc là je suis en voisin je
peux venir passer en X 2 et c'est tout
ce que je peux faire ici je suis un peu
sur ce mode je peux pas passer
jusqu'en x 10 je peux pas bien moduler
pareil je peux pas passer en ultra grand
angle je pense qu'il est limité
peut-être sur la capacité de calcul
pourtant il y en a quand même derrière
avec le stand dragon mais on peut
uniquement faire ça foin x 2 après de
toute façon ce que je vous conseille de
façon c'est de venir vous rapprocher
parce que comme on a un X3 et demi
optique ça peut rapidement être
limitatif mais à mon avis on reste sur
la même optique ici c'est-à-dire
l'optique principal c'est celle-là x 2
vous voyez les façons de je suis sur mon
optique principale j'ai un obstrué et je
vois qu'en fait c'est ça donc c'est un
zoom x 2 numérique qu'on a ici donc ça
ça me permet effectivement de venir
filmer en flat si je veux faire un petit
peu de création je peux bien zoomer un
petit peu je peux venir prendre des
choses un peu au sol si j'ai envie de
faire un peu de créa ça reste très
stabilisé donc ça c'est hyper sinon ça
c'est vachement cool donc ça c'est le
mode qui va m'intéresser moi surtout
pour venir créer donc là vous voyez hop
là je filme c'est hyper stabilisé je me
déplace comme ça vous voyez ça bouge pas
bouge pas une oreille sur le coco hop là
on vient on reprend en haut on vient on
se déplace je le tiens à la main c'est
hyper stabilisé c'est assez
impressionnant pour voir que ce soit de
l'optique je reviens au sol je vais
filmer un petit peu les façons c'est
hyper smooth alors après il y a un truc
qui est cool c'est que vous pouvez
mettre un quadrillage et une ligne de
l'horizon pour être sûr de toujours
avoir votre horizon bien maintenu on
peut venir aussi filmer un petit peu hop
là sur le haut comme ça ça me permet
mais après de venir faire mon étalonnage
et ça c'est quand même vachement cool
tout en sachant qu'en plus je vais avoir
un petit voyant qui m'indique ma durée
d'enregistrement donc là je vois que je
suis en train d'enregistrer ça clignote
en rouge je vois ma durer
d'enregistrement je vois ma durée totale
je peux enregistrer jusqu'à 15 minutes
ici activer le flash ou pas très
honnêtement le flash j'en ai absolument
pas du tout besoin et je en même temps
venir déclencher et prendre une petite
photo PAF comme ça voilà donc ce mode là
il est pratique pour tous ceux qui
veulent créer du contenu et aller
beaucoup plus loin pour tous les
créateurs de contenu on peut venir le
faire on peut venir travailler sur on
peut venir modifier ses fichiers et ça
c'est quand même vachement bien voyez la
typiquement j'ai mon fichier qui est
complètement flat donc ce que je peux
venir faire la surf Final Cut Pro mais
vous pouvez le faire aussi son premier
pro je vais mettre un petit
gadgetmundleyer et je vais venir me
mettre un petit plugin qui va me servir
pour ma colo alors après il y a
différentes façons de faire mais moi je
vais faire comme ça ici je vais utiliser
ciné magride que je vais mettre ici hop
là juste là je vais dans mon outil de
contrôle ici et je vais pouvoir venir
travailler alors il y a différentes
façons de venir bosser mais moi je vous
montre comme ça là il me faut un peu
plus d'ombre vous voyez je vais monter
un peu mes lumières je fais gaffe que ça
crame pas là je le vois au niveau de son
front voilà au niveau de la température
de couleur moi ça ne va pas mal comme ça
ici on peut venir un petit peu comme ça
ici je peux venir me mettre ensuite un
petit LED sur le dessus on va se mettre
celui là c'est un peu fort on vient
diminuer un petit peu vous voyez ça
dépend effectivement après l'ambiance
que je vais avoir là c'est un poil vert
donc là je vais venir comme ça casser un
peu ici là vous voyez voilà ça comme ça
et faire gaffe à concombre faut quand
même que ce soit pas dégueu voyez je
pars de là quand même d'un fichier hyper
flat et ensuite je vais le coloriser
donc là je peux bien faire ma
colorimétrie directement comme je le
fais sur n'importe quel projet que je
vais pouvoir monter par même si
aujourd'hui c'est plus moi qui monte
mais si je veux le faire je peux venir
le faire ici directement donc voyez hop
flat avec la colo donc j'ai toutes les
informations qui sont ici à l'intérieur
de mon fichier vous voyez et lorsque je
mets lecture je peux venir virer ma
colorimétrie mettre ma colorimétrie
directement et lui donner différents
looks ça qui est intéressant également
avec le fait de vouloir appliquer cette
colorimétrie là c'est que si je retourne
dans mon logiciel de contrôle je vous
montre effectivement que j'utilise la
ceutte là mais j'en ai énormément donc
ça va dépendre après vous de ce que vous
avez de l'effet que vous voulez venir
donner ici mais si vous voulez donner un
côté un peu plus chaud ben vous pouvez
ça va dépendre voyez un truc ce truc là
vous voyez il y a un côté comme ça qui
peut être sympa aussi qui est assez joli
après ça dépend vraiment du du look
qu'on veut venir donner mais en tout cas
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'avec ce
smartphone comme je filme mon flat et
bien après je peux me garder toutes les
possibilités pour tout ce que je vais
vouloir faire derrière en
post-production alors pour toute la
partie vidéo je vais vous montrer deux
petits films qui ont été tournés avec le
smartphone comme ça vous verrez le
premier on roule dans la nuit vous allez
voir qu'on peut vraiment venir filmer
dans la nuit sans aucun problème ça se
passe bien évidemment tout ça avec
Leonor Magic 5 Pro fait du scout
directement dans Prague
[Musique]
ça se passe dans des conditions avec une
lumière qui n'est pas naturelle c'est la
patinoire de Prague s'est tourné la nuit
je fais du hockey sur glace et c'est pas
moi de dire parce que je suis très
mauvais enquis sur glace et vous allez
voir également qu'il y a un rendu qui
est très très bien on y va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'on voit et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que même en condition je veux dire
de faible luminosité la nuit on peut
venir filmer la nuit on a rendu qui est
très bon grâce à ce capteur de 50
mégapixels ça marche très bien et si
vous regardez effectivement si toute la
partie sur le hockey sur glace on est
sur des lumières artificielles mais pour
autant la qualité est là c'est bien
alors le point faible qu'on va avoir sur
ce smartphone c'est que le micro sera
pas parfait donc si vous voulez venir
capter du son je vous conseille de venir
prendre un micro externe pour maximiser
il existe des petits micros qu'on peut
venir brancher directement en
USB C dans son smartphone pour améliorer
significativement l'expérience donc ça
c'est quand même très cool il y a des
solutions externes et je vous le
recommande réellement mais pour venir
filmer avec un smartphone à la main pour
toutes les personnes qui veulent venir
créer pour des réseaux Tik Tok pour de
l'Instagram reels pour du Facebook
compagnie on peut bien le faire on n'ira
pas aussi loin bien évidemment sur
Youtube pour de la vidéo comment on le
fait là parce que la qualité à un moment
bon on va buter un petit peu et il en
manquera quand même pour avoir une vraie
qualité pour tourner un beau film comme
ça mais pour avoir la même qualité que
ce que j'ai là tout de suite on n'est
pas dans les mêmes budgets non plus là
vous voyez j'ai une caméra qui va coûter
4500 balles vers US mon smartphone même
s'il est très bien 1200 balles mais
c'est pas la même chose non plus c'est
pas le même capteur mais pour je dirais
du YouTube shorts pour l'Instagram Real
c'est pour le Tik Tok ça ira
parfaitement bien et ça marche vous
l'avez vu une fois de plus très bien et
c'est très bien maîtrisé tout en sachant
que dans ce mode là il y a un truc
vachement bien pour tous les créateurs
de contenu c'est que si vous venez dans
les paramètres et bien vous voyez vous
pouvez venir filmer en 4K alors pas du
caca ici de la 4K 16 9 ça ira très bien
on peut faire de la 4K également 21/9 si
vous voulez un format plus cinémascar
vous pouvez mais surtout ce qui est bien
c'est le nombre d'images par seconde
vous avez plus le choix vous avez du 30
du 60 fps mais on peut également mettre
du 24 FPS si ça peut vous intéresser
voilà après c'est au choix de chacun en
fonction des besoins de création que
chacun alors il y a cercle la vidéo mais
il y a également la photo plutôt votre
professionnelle c'est le mode vous le
voyez il s'appelle pro en fait c'est
pour venir shooter en haut smiley cool
parce que vous pouvez venir choisir ce
que vous voulez là typiquement sur JPEG
je peux passer au JPEG elle JPEG large
je vais être 150 mégapixels full capteur
ok ça vient pas à me réunir plusieurs
pixels et après je vais avoir mon mode
rond qui va être pas mal parce qu'il
paraîtra effectivement de venir
retravailler sur du Lightroom ça ça
s'intéresse plutôt au créateur qui
veulent vraiment venir shooter avec ça
retravailler des images qui va venir
récupérer un peu de couleur un peu de
contraste bref si vous aimez la retouche
vous savez ce mot de rela qui est
pratique claque on prend le coco avec en
photo vous pouvez venir modifier votre
balance des blancs vous pouvez tout
régler ici donc si vous êtes amoureux de
photos vous pouvez venir vous marrer
directement passer sur un mode
professionnel vous c'est très complet je
vous sélectionne trois photos que j'ai
ici et qui sont prises ça c'est un DNG
donc c'est le vrai rôle donc là je vais
pouvoir venir vraiment retravailler
après mon image si je le souhaite venir
la saturer un peu pour y récupérer
derrière et jouer ici un petit peu donc
là je suis en rouge je peux venir
retravailler mon fichier si je regarde
le poids de mon fichier vous voyez
celle-là la DNG j'ai un pote 21 méga
donc bon on est quand même sur un
fichier un peu sérieux on peut venir lui
ramener également un peu de texture
jouer sur la clarté personnellement je
vais pas trop en mettre donc là ma photo
est pourrie parce qu'on était en train
de filmer et que c'était pas le cadre
qu'on voulait mais je peux venir bosser
ça moi ce qui m'a surtout m’intéresser
c'est venir bosser plutôt ces plans là
là voyez que je trouve très jolie donc
là je suis pas sur du DNG je suis sur du
jpeg mais du jpeg hot def je suis sur du
17 mega au niveau de l'info et là je
peux venir après travailler un petit peu
mon expo casser un peu maison et mes
noirs je peux venir après re saturer
j'ai pas mal d'informations quand même
ici dans ce fichier là vous voyez si je
vais faire ressortir mes nuages tac je
peux venir bosser un peu ici au niveau
de la texture et au niveau de la clarté
après c'est du Lightroom donc on va pas
se faire un tuto Lightroom mais voyez on
a quand même de quoi de quoi venir se
marrer ici on peut quand même venir
éditer ses photos et comme on a pas mal
d'informations ici ça c'est plutôt pas
mal donc là j'ai celle-là j'ai aussi
celle-là qui est pas mal alors après je
peux venir faire une colorimétrie si je
le souhaite faire un peu de Color
greading tu me ramener un petit peu de
vert ici un peu de matière un peu plus
chaude ici et je vais faire gaffe dans
les hautes lumières je vais me mettre un
peu de bleu c'est un peu violine je veux
dire que c'est après là je peux vouloir
venir saturé davantage un petit peu mes
couleurs moi j'aime bien quand il y a de
la matière sur les images de venir
rajouter vraiment de la texture ici il y
a un côté qui est très agréable baisser
la clarté et après je peux jouer sur la
correction du vol exposer un peu mais je
fais gaffe la voyez ici là c'est un peu
cramé au niveau des hautes lumières
après je peux venir retravailler
différemment donc une fois de plus
l'idée c'est pas de se faire un petit
tuto Lightroom mais pour autant voyez
j'arrive quand même à sortir des choses
qui sont pas dégueu en partant d'un
fichier de base si je vous mets
l'original vous voyez on part de là et
on arrive là donc on peut aller encore
plus loin faire plus de choses donc j'ai
de l'information et c'est ça qui est
intéressant de venir shooter ici en haut
directement et voyez je peux venir après
recadrer ma prochaine mon image et j'ai
pas du tout de de qualité alors après
davantage vous voyez si je viens vous
ruiner un peu fatalement mais c'est
quand même relativement acceptable et je
peux venir recadrer et venir travailler
mes photos comme je le souhaite ici
alors après vous avez d'autres petits
modes vous allez dans votre mode plus là
vous allez avoir le mode super macro bon
pour venir shooter de la macro un grand
classique j'ai déjà montré le Time Lapse
ok why notes scan un document le
panorama bon si on veut alors il y a un
mode qui peut être marrant c'est une
mode storia alors je vous montre en fait
ça vous montre quelques petites
séquences pour venir réaliser ce que
font soit là en dual view vous en avez
celui là dessus également duelview ça
c'est sur un mode simple en fait vous
avez vous marque 14 secondes 4 séquences
ça vous permet de reproduire un peu ce
qu'ils font ça peut vous donner une
source d'inspiration même si c'est pas
le truc le plus fou du monde ok pourquoi
pas et puis après vous avez un mode qui
peut être assez marrant alors là-haut
très résolution ok si on veut le
filigrane bof ralenti c'est le mode
multi vidéo et là le multi vidéo je me
vois on voit le coco en face là-bas et
je peux venir moduler et regarder je
viens alterner ici directement donc soit
moi je suis tout petit je peux me
déplacer moi directement dans l'image et
je l'ai lu en face je peux venir
complètement personnaliser donc ça ça
peut être marrant ça dépend de la
création et c'est fait par exemple une
interview et que vous voulez avoir votre
interlocuteur et vous en on peut venir
te poser faire tout ça avec un seul
smartphone et avec des caméras qui sont
quand même bien donc ça c'est cool on va
avoir également je regarde hop là
l'arrière qui va être plein ou j'ai bien
la reconnaissance du visage de mon
interlocuteur en face assez bien je vais
avoir uniquement ma caméra à moi bref
vous voyez il y a pas mal de petites
options qu'on peut venir ici choisir
personnaliser c'est un mode pour les
créateurs donc en fait ce qu'il faut
vraiment venir retenir ici ce qui est
intéressant et que ce smartphone c'est
qu'on voit que vous avez beaucoup
d'options à 360 degrés pour les
créateurs que ce soit pour venir faire
de la photo un peu normal grand ordre
ultra grand temps que tu es l'objectif
pas trop loin x au-delà de ça c'est pas
ouf pas ouf la macro qui est très bien
en passant le capteur 50 mégapixels de
votre ultra grand-angle c'est cool vous
voyez que si vous voulez venir avoir des
photos également en haut on peut
vraiment travailler ça c'est cool pour
toute la création vidéo aussi c'est très
complet c'est stabilisé c'est bien ça
bouge pas et ça croyez-moi avec moi
c'est extrêmement important et puis vous
avez ensuite ce mode pour venir filmer
soit en flat en log soit avec une
colorimétrie avec des lettres pour
donner une ambiance si vous le souhaitez
vous avez pas envie de vous emmerder de
la post-production ou alors venir à
filmer caméra avant arrière en même
temps bref en fait ce qui est
intéressant avec ce smartphone c'est
qu'il va être extrêmement polyvalent si
on veut venir faire de la création avec
smartphone directement dans la poche
tout ça bien évidemment booster avec de
l'intelligence artificielle grâce au
sein dragon 8 GN2 mais ça je vous
renvoie bah précédente vidéo pour tout
savoir sur ce smartphone et puis surtout
vous je sais pas qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez comment vous le trouvez ce Honor
Magic 5 Pro est-ce qu'il vous aille
parce qu'il vous botte est-ce qu'il vous
tente ce qu'il vous tente pas qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de toutes ces photos de
toutes ces vidéos qu'on peut faire avec
le mode nuit également qui est aussi
super cool et super intéressant c'est
bien parce qu'en fait au nord c'est une
marque qui évolue énormément on a vu
plein de choses à arriver on les a vu
s'émanciper on les a vu récupéré les
services Google on les voit avec un
écosystème extrêmement complet et puis
là on les voit avec un très beau
smartphone déjà une dernière c'était
chouette avec le Honor Magic 4 pro le
Honor Magic 5 Pro va encore plus loin
perso j'aime bien dites-moi vous ce que
vous en pensez en bas dans les
commentaires et nous on se retrouve très
bientôt bien évidemment pour faire quoi
pour parler de Take ça c'est chouette je
vous embrasse à bientôt Ciao
[Musique]